münchen fünfter september
1972 es ist genau 14 als acht
palästinensische terroristen über das
tor 25 a im olympischen dorf klettern 25
minuten später stürmen sie schwer
bewaffnet die koloniestraße 31 die
unterkunft der israelischen
olympiamannschaft
ich bitte sie als staatsoberhaupt dieses
landes und dem namen der bundesrepublik
deutschland
um vergebung und vergebung für den
mangelnden schutz der israelischen
athleten
damals bei den olympischen spielen in
münchen
und für die mangelnde aufklärung danach
dafür
das geschehen konnte
was geschehen ist
über 20 stunden lang vor den augen der
welt versuchen die vollkommen
überforderten deutschen behörden die
geiselnahme zu beenden und scheitern am
ende kläglich nullo 10 flughafen
fürstenfeldbruck schüsse fallen ein
hubschrauber wird gesprengt alle elf
israelischen geiseln sind unsere
deutsche verantwortung zu bekennen hier
und heute und für die zukunft
die lückenlose analyse des dramas von
münchen jetzt in einem bild tv spezial
guten abend und beginnen wir am vorabend
der geiselnahme neun stunden bevor die
ersten zwei israelis sterben
das ist 19 uhr im ausverkauften
olympiastadion von münchen lässt die
erst 16 jährige schülerin ulrike
meyfarth die hochsprunglatte auf nie
dagewesene einen meter 92 legen sie ist
völliger außenseiterin aber sie schafft
es goldmedaille weltrekord deutschland
flippt aus im stadion vor den fernseher
nur nahezu zeitgleich wird der
amerikaner mark spitz im nahegelegenen
schwimmstadion seine siebte goldmedaille
bei diesen spielen unglaublich auch das
gab es noch nie die olympischen spiele
1972 ein sommermärchen genau so wie es
sein sollte berauschten deutschland und
die welt mit einem lächeln schlafen nur
eine gruppe
terroristen weiß zu diesem zeitpunkt
dass die menschen mit einem schock
wieder aufwachen würden
es soll eine zeit der sportlichen
höchstleistungen und spannenden
wettbewerbe werden und tatsächlich die
welt feiert lacht und konkurriert
friedlich im sportlichen wettkampf bei
den olympischen spielen in münchen
1972 fast zehn tage lang bis zum 5
september als acht palästinensische
attentäter der gruppe schwarzer
september den terror nach deutschland
tragen
bremen kassierte israelische mannschaft
ein bei der fehlgeschlagenen
befreiungsaktion sterben elf sportler
ein polizist und fünf terroristen
genau 50 jahren bringen am frühen morgen
acht schwer bewaffnete terroristen in
das olympische dorf ein dieses wird von
den deutschen sicherheitsbehörden nicht
besonders bewacht praktisch jeder kann
sich dort frei bewegen auch die
unterkunft des israelischen teams ist
nicht bewacht die forderung der
palästinenser
200 in israel inhaftierte menschen
sollen freigelassen werden sowie andreas
baader und ulrike meinhof die zwei
spitzen der raf andernfalls würden sie
ihre geiseln erschießen hundertschaften
der polizei rücken an regeln die
eingänge der wohnblocks im olympischen
dorf ab
aber schnell klar die deutschen behörden
sind vollkommen überfordert
übernahme durch israelisches
spezialteams der erfahrung mit
geiselnahmen haben wird mehrfach von
deutschen behörden abgelehnt
bundesinnenminister bayerischer
innenminister und polizeipräsident
sprechen mit den geiseln leiten die
verhandlungen mit den terror ist die
geiselnehmer nehmen den vorschlag an vom
flughafen fürstenfeldbruck nach ägypten
zu fliegen die polizei bereitet sich auf
die befreiung der geiseln auf dem
flughafen vor kurz vor abflug in
fürstenfeldbruck kommt es zur
katastrophe
obwohl die polizei schützen wieder mit
zielfernrohren nachtsichtgeräten noch
mit funkgeräten ausgestattet sind
eröffnen sie das feuer es folgt ein
wilder schusswechsel die geiselnehmer
beschießen den tower und erschießen
mehrere sportler sie sprengen ein
hubschrauber mit einer handgranate in
die luft er brennt aus mit vier
israelischen geiseln darin es bei
anbruch des neuen tages wird das ganze
ausmaß der katastrophal gescheiterten
geiselbefreiung sichtbar alle neuen
israelischen sportler sterben ein
polizist und sechs terroristen sind der
einsatz der deutschen polizei ist ein
debakel das schärfte vorwürfe an ihrer
vorgehensweise nach sich zieht und viele
sprach und ratlos macht
die geschehnisse vom 5 september treffen
polizei sicherheitskräfte organisatoren
und die politische führung völlig
unvorbereitet auch wenn es zuvor
hinweise auf einen möglichen terrorakt
die sportwettkämpfe werden für einen tag
unterbrochen und dann mit dieser höchst
umstrittenen parole vor mir sitzt
[Musik]
seit einem halben jahrhundert wird
darüber gestritten ob das drama durch
bessere vorbereitung hätte verhindert
werden können und ob die
verantwortlichen angemessen reagiert
haben die politik zieht drei wochen nach
dem anschlag konsequenzen die
spezialeinheit gsg 9 wird gegründet für
den anti-terror-einsatz und zur
befreiung von geiseln zudem gibt der
staat geld 1972 und 2002 rund 4,6
millionen euro als humanitäre geste für
die betroffenen
heute am 15 september wird nun in
münchen der ermordeten gedacht doch das
gedenken zum fünfzigsten jahrestag wird
von diskussionen begleitet die
hinterbliebenen der getöteten geiseln
verhandeln über entschädigungszahlungen
mit der bundesregierung drohen die
trauerfeier zu boykottieren das vor
wenigen tagen die einigung 30 millionen
euro zahlt die bundesregierung 50 jahre
nach den schwarzen tagen
1972 in münchen
[Musik]
und unser reporter andreas bachner ist
jetzt im ehemaligen olympischen dorf da
wo damals die israelischen athleten
wohnten und wo heute auch kränze
niedergelegt wurden wie sieht es dort
heute aus
ja das olympische dorf ist optisch quasi
unverändert nach 50 jahren hier im
hintergrund hinter mir sieht man die
hochhäuser des olympischen dorfes und
hier leben inzwischen sehr sehr viele
studenten ist leben wahnsinnig viele
familien hier auch viele ausländische
studenten senioren ein bunter mix ist
das hier und es ist ein sehr beliebtes
wohnquartiere mittlerweile geworden die
menschen in münchen lieben das
olympische dorf das olympiadorf den
olympiapark ist es ein naherholungsraum
es gibt viele sportstätten viele
konzerte die hier stattfinden die leute
genießen das leben hier können hier alle
besorgungen machen müssen gar nicht in
die stadt fahren denn es ist eine kleine
stadt innerhalb der stadt und trotzdem
ist man in nur 15 minuten mitten am
marienplatz also ein sehr beliebtes
wohnquartiere mittlerweile und wir sind
jetzt in der koloniestraße hier und wenn
man die kolonie straße entlangläuft und
hier die straße 31 kommt hinter mir dann
würde man das gar nicht vermuten was
hier passiert ist vor 50 jahren hier
gibt es eine kleine gedenktafel an dem
haus an dem die namen der elf getöteten
athleten stehen ansonsten erinnert hier
nicht wirklich viel daran heute wurden
hier kränze niedergelegt
das haus ist auch kaum verändert zu den
bildern von damals da ist inzwischen das
max-planck-institut drin mit
wissenschaftlichen mitarbeitern und
heute wurden hier kränze niedergelegt
und sie sehen es hinter mir aktuell ist
der bereich auch gesperrte sind
polizeikräfte da denn nach der
gedenkfeier am fliegerhorst in
fürstenfeldbruck haben sich einige der
opferfamilien spontan dazu entschieden
wieder hierher an diesen ort zu kommen
und hier auch des attentats und ihrer
familien und opfern zu gedenken
ja
so spricht die familien an es gab im
vorfeld wir haben es vorhin dem bericht
gehört auch unstimmigkeiten wir können
auch sagen es gab streit über die
behandlung der angehörigen der opfer
auch über die höhe der abfindungen war
es nach diesen auseinandersetzungen wo
sie ja sogar drohten nicht zu kommen
inklusive des israelischen
staatspräsidenten eine würdige
gedenkveranstaltung heute dann
ja es war eine sehr würdige und auch
eine sehr emotionale veranstaltung
allein der ort wenn man dort ist und die
gedenkfeier hat nur wenige meter von dem
ort stattgefunden wo die helikopter
standen wo die geiseln im kugelhagel
starben der tower hat sich auch optisch
fast nicht verändert es ist wie eine
zeitkapsel dort als wäre die zeit stehen
geblieben allein wenn man dort ist wird
man emotional und die familien haben
sich nach dieser einigung nachdem diese
entschädigungszahlung geflossen sind und
auch eine expertenkommission eingesetzt
werden soll um das alles aufzuarbeiten
haben sich doch kurzfristig entschieden
zu kommen und haben auch unisono
gedankt und gesagt dass es dass es sehr
wichtig ist für sie ich habe zum
beispiel mit dem münchner
oberbürgermeister dieter reiter
gesprochen der die familien auch heute
hier empfangen hat hier im olympischen
dorf der auch sagte er hat den eindruck
es war den familien vor allem wichtig
diese expertenkommission diese
aufarbeitung der geschehnisse und vor
allem diese entschuldigung und diese
entschuldigung haben sie heute bekommen
sowohl vom ministerpräsidenten markus
söder als auch vom bundespräsidenten
frank walter steinmeier die sich beide
die sich beide entschuldigt haben und
die familien direkt angesprochen haben
um vergebung gebeten haben und
verzeihung gebeten haben für die fehler
die passiert sind denn hier sind sehr
viele fehler passiert im vorfeld gab es
kaum sicherheitsvorkehrungen die
terroristen konnten nachts ungehindert
über die zäune klettern hier wenige
hundert meter entfernt
man hat mir ein lied für sportler die
nacht feiern waren die polizisten hier
die patrouilliert sind waren kaum
bewaffnet münchen wollte sich als
offenes liberales als offener liberaler
ort der olympischen spiele präsentieren
und auch die befreiungsaktion sowohl
hier vor ort als auch in
fürstenfeldbruck ist komplett missglückt
danach gab es auch keine aufarbeitung
ich habe auch mit polizisten gesprochen
die damals im einsatz waren die alle
sagten es war seltsam denn es gab
überhaupt keine einsatzbesprechung
danach jahrelang ist tot schweigen und
der emotionalste moment das war an die
spitze die witwe des ermordeten athleten
josef spitzer die gesagt hat eine stunde
nach dem attentat war sich hier was ich
hier in diesem haus im ersten stock dort
wo ihr mann gestorben ist der erschossen
wurde dann verblutet ist und sie hat das
blut gesehen an den wänden serbien hats
gesehen und sie hat sich damals
geschworen dass sie nicht ruhe geben
wird bis das aufgearbeitet wird und
heute hat sie sehr emotional gesagt sie
ist endlich angekommen sie kann endlich
ruhen und auch ihrem mann kann endlich
ruhe
ist auch nach an einem sehr emotionalen
tag in münchen fielen dank andreas und
wir wollen in der tat noch einmal
zurückschauen auf diese katastrophalen
gut 21 stunden damals 17 tote elf
israelische geiseln darunter ein
deutscher polizist und fünf
palästinensische terroristen inzwischen
dann der sechste september als all dies
vorbei sind noch am selben tag verkündet
der ioc-chef games must go on die spiele
müssen weitergehen bild chefreporter
peter held hat den strippenzieher
getroffen von damals hat er
akteneinsicht in bnd unterlagen und ist
jetzt bei mir im studio hat sich über
jahrzehnte mit diesem fall beschäftigt
peter wir haben gerade von andreas schon
an einen kleinen einblick in die
versäumnisse die es dort gab gegeben
vielleicht als erstes die frage hätte
das alles verhindert werden können also
nach meinem dafürhalten ja
wir haben das war ja auch im beitrag
konnte man das hören und sehen auch wir
haben katastrophale fehler seitens der
deutschen sicherheitsbehörden
feststellen können direkt danach aber
eben auch danach in der schlechten
aufarbeitung und was eben dazu kommt ist
wir haben aufgrund von einer bild
anfrage jetzt akteneinsicht bekommen in
akten vom bundesnachrichtendienst ich
will die mal zeigen das sind die
klassifizierter hat jetzt diese akten
waren aber sehr unter als streng geheim
eingestuft worden und sie dokumentieren
eben das versagen der deutschen behörden
und eben auch eine gewisse art von
arrogant ist also man muss sagen zu
diesem zeitpunkt am 5 september ist eben
mit einer sondermaschine der damalige
mossad chefs wie zamir mit einem anderen
agenten mit einem top agenten vom schin
bet vom israelischen geheimdienst
inlandsgeheimdienst nach deutschland
geflogen und sie haben aktiv ihre hilfe
angeboten aktiv gesagt wir können
elitetruppen wir können elite-einheiten
schicken die die geiselbefreiung
durchführen können das wurde kategorisch
abgelehnt das ist schon mal der erste
fehler gewesen dann hat man versucht
zeit zu gewinnen mit dem geiselnehmer zu
sprechen ein mitarbeiter des mossad
konnte arabische dialekte er hätte also
mit denen sprechen können das wurde auch
abgelehnt und dann was wir ja gerade
auch gehört haben diese furchtbare
ausrüstung und diese schlechte
ausbildung der deutschen
sicherheitsbehörden es sind nur fünf
scharfschützen eingesetzt worden für
acht attentäter die hatten keine
zielfernrohre die hatten auch keine
nachtsichtgeräte und sie waren eben auch
nicht per funk miteinander verbunden und
aus diesen akten geht eben hervor das
will ich mal zitieren dass der
nachrichtenchef dann gesagt hat die
worte die mehr zu dem ihm angekündigten
scharfschützen fand die dann bei
dunkelheit schießen nur mit pistolen und
maschinenpistolen ausgerüstet waren
ließen an deutlichkeit nicht zu wünschen
übrig das heißt wer hat getobt am 6
september als er mit dem präsidenten des
bundesnachrichtendienstes
zusammengekommen ist mit des bnd und hat
gesagt also was ihr hier abgezogen hat
uns der bnd aber die deutschen
sicherheitsbehörden war eine totale ein
totales chaos complete mesz sagte er das
hätte man verhindern können wenn man
sich noch einmal zurück versetzt wir
haben ja einige der bilder auch gesehen
wie das alles ablief da sieht man
beispielsweise den deutschen
bundesinnenminister genscher der rede
direkt mit den palästinensischen mit dem
anführer der terroristen beispielsweise
die unterhalten sich darüber ob man das
ultimatum noch mal verlängern könnte und
so weiter und so fort der
bundesinnenminister die stehen da im
pulk zwar an und da sind bürgermeister
das erinnert so ein bisschen an gladbeck
an die szenen und denn die bilder von
gladbeck wo eben auch reporter oder
zivilisten mit mit mit den geiselnehmern
verhandelt haben also das zeigt eben
dass man überhaupt nicht auf diese
situation vorbereitet war man hatte
keinen plan aber auch keinen plan b das
ging alles sehr schnell hintereinander
und da wurde eben auch den israelis
gesagt die pläne stehen wir wissen der
flughafen fürstenfeldbruck ist
abgesichert wir können da was machen das
stimmte natürlich überhaupt nicht aber
auch noch vorher eine szene die für mich
auch beispielhaft dafür steht wie das
alles schief gehen da hatten sicher dann
die polizisten als sportler verkleidet
den wurden dann puma anzüge gegeben dann
wurden die aufs dach gebracht und
sollten von da eine befreiungsaktion
schatten das wurde aber alles live im
fernsehen übertragen und oma hatte
vergessen aber vorher den fernsehempfang
für die terroristen abzustellen das
heißt sie konnten also zu schauen und
konnten live im fernsehen sehen was da
an zugriffs vorbereitungen statt von
auch das ist ein punkt der in diesen
akten steht diesen ehemals streng
geheime akten dass die israelis gesagt
haben wie kann man nur oder wie kann man
keine nachrichtensperre verhängt das
heißt die hatten im prinzip jede art von
taktik konnten sie voraus sehen sie
wussten genau wo welche polizisten
versuchen in welche räumlichkeiten
reinzukommen also schlimmer kann man es
eigentlich nicht machen das zeigt eben
dass eben überhaupt keine
präventivmaßnahmen überhaupt in den
köpfen der sicherheitsbehörden
stattgefunden haben also man hat damit
gar nicht gerechnet was natürlich
blödsinn ist wenn man weiß dass zu
diesem zeitpunkt in den 70er jahren
natürlich viele terroranschläge auch auf
israel stattgefunden haben da hätte man
natürlich besonders vorsichtig sein muss
man hätte sie besonders schützen müssen
und man muss natürlich mit plänen mit
ersatz plänen auch antreten und sagen
was ist wenn die geiseln genommen werden
und das hat nicht stattgefunden dass wir
in deutschland hatten die raf baader
meinhof das war nicht so als wenn wir
noch nie etwas von terror gehört hatten
zu der zeit das ist richtig und diese
art von terror oder geiselnahmen hatte
offenbar in den köpfen auch gar nicht
stattgefundenen sicherheits worden es
gab keine spezialeinheiten die
bewaffnung ließ zu wünschen übrig das
hat man auch gesehen in fürstenfeldbruck
da wurde mit pistolen auf das rollfeld
auf das vorfeld geschossen mit
maschinenpistolen also die haben eine
streuung heute oder ein normalerweise
sagt man das wichtigste ist der schutz
der geiseln das wurde überhaupt nicht
beinhaltet da wo der rhein geschossen
was die schwarte kracht auf deutsch
gesagt und da kam es eben deswegen zu
diesem furchtbaren
opferzahlen und das war eben ein weckruf
daneben das eben dann auch später die
gsg9 gegründet wurde aber natürlich viel
zu spät auch wenn man noch mal daran
denkt der eigentliche plan war ja
sozusagen nur scheinbar auf das auf die
forderungen einzugehen die geiseln aus
zu flügen nach nach kairo nach ägypten
da wollte man dann in fürstenfeldbruck
wo dann also die lufthansa maschine war
wollte man dann verkleidete als piloten
oder oder flugbegleiter verkleidete
polizisten dort in dieses flugzeug geben
die dann die terroristen ausschalten
sollten wenn die ins flugzeug rein
kommen da hat man aber dann offenbar
irgendwelche streifenpolizisten
sozusagen genommen und die haben gesagt
das ist ein himmelfahrtskommando das
machen wir nicht richtig das waren
streifenpolizisten die waren vielleicht
ich will das nicht despektierlich
beschreiben aber die waren dafür da
vielleicht um den verkehr zu regeln oder
irgendwas die waren natürlich weder mit
den mit der waffentechnologie noch mit
der körperlichkeit noch mit der mit dem
know how einer geiselbefreiung
ausgerüstet das ist fahrlässig das war
ein völlig unerfahrene junge männer die
sind dann kurz vorher abgehauen die
haben gesagt das machen wir nicht also
das ist ein himmelfahrtskommando will
sind weg hier und so konnte neben die
terroristen auch über dieses rollfeld
gehen also da gab es überhaupt keinen
plan was eben auch zwei zamir beobachtet
hat er hat geschrieben auch dann oder
oder hat sich beschwert gesagt also bis
zum
bis zum eintreffen der geiseln lief
eigentlich alles ganz gut was danach
passiert ist beschreibt spottet jeder
beschreibung und man hat noch mal
nochmal immer wieder gesagt wir bieten
wir bieten unsere hilfe an wurde immer
abgelehnt also das zeugt von einer
gewissen arroganz und ja man kann es
eigentlich gar nicht mit worten
beschreiben warum man nicht diese hilfe
dieser wirklich professionellen und
terror erfahrenen experten in anspruch
genommen hat es ist ja immer es ist ja
immer dass es auch daran liegt man kann
nicht einen ausländischen geheimdienst
auf deutschem boden operieren lassen
wieder wir wollen uns das ganze nochmal
anschauen in einem minutenprotokoll was
da alles schief gegangen ist wir haben
da mal was vorbereitet
danach kommt die
14 8 palästinenser klettern über den
zaun des olympischen dorfes
postmitarbeiter sehen die männer denken
sich aber nichts dabei 4 uhr 35 die
terroristen betreten das haus
koloniestraße 31 dort ist das quartier
der israelischen olympiamannschaft die
araber stürmen das appartement
erschießen zwei israelis und nehmen neun
weitere israelische sportler als geiseln
506 alle verfügbaren funkstreifen werden
zum olympischen dorf geschickt
36 scharfschützen werden ins olympische
dorf verlegt
46 walther tröger bürgermeister des
olympischen dorfes und willi daume
präsident des nationalen olympischen
komitees treffen ein sprechen mit den
terroristen die fordern die freilassung
von 220 palästinensern aus israelischen
gefängnissen die stellen ein ultimatum
bis 9 uhr dieses ultimatum wird über den
tag hinweg immer wieder verlängert
15 uhr 38 die olympischen spiele werden
unterbrochen 20 30 der krisenstab
vereinbart mit den terroristen das auf
dem flughafen fürstenfeldbruck ein
flugzeug bereitgestellt wird mit dem sie
samt geiseln nach kairo fliegen können
die deutsche einsatzleitung hat zwei
pläne die terroristen auf dem weg zu den
hubschrauber im olympischen dorf zu
überwältigen oder auf dem
militärflughafen fünf scharfschützen
werden nach fürstenfeldbruck verlegt da
die einsatzleitung glaubt es mit nur
fünf und nicht mit acht terroristen zu
tun zu haben
21 30 zwei hubschrauber des
bundesgrenzschutzes landen dem
olympischen dorf
22 06 ein führer und geiseln steigen an
der koloniestraße in einen bus ein zum
ersten mal er kennt die einsatzleitung
dass es acht terroristen sind und nicht
fünf wie bisher angenommen die in der
tiefgarage des olympischen dorfes
geplante befreiungsaktion wird abgesagt
weil sie zu gefährlich für die geiseln
seien 22 uhr 18 und hörer und geiseln
besteigen die beiden hubschrauber alle
geiseln sind an den händen gefesselt 22
35 die hubschrauber landen den
fürstenfeldbruck aus jedem hubschrauber
steigen palästinenser aus und beziehen
post polizisten die in fürstenfeldbruck
als flugpersonal und mechaniker
verkleidet die terroristen in der
passagiermaschine überwältigen sollen
weigern sich den auftrag auszuführen wir
haben angst dass ihre verkleidung sofort
durchschaut würde
22 uhr 38 nachdem zwei der entführer die
bereitgestellte lufthansa-maschine
inspiziert haben schaltet die polizei
die lichter am flughafen aus und setzt
einen grellen strahl 1 auf befehl des
bayerischen innenministers bruno merk
eröffneten die scharfschützen das feuer
drei terroristen werden tödlich
getroffen die anderen erschießen aber
daraufhin acht geiseln eine weitere wird
verletzt im tower wird ein deutscher
polizist von einer kugel in den kopf
getroffen erste und
23 uhr 23 ein terrorist wird von einem
scharfschützen getroffen unter ihm
explodiert eine handgranate 04 ein
panzerwagen der polizei fällt auf das
flugfeld ein palästinenser wurde eine
handgranate in einen hubschrauber in dem
die letzte noch lebende geisel ist der
hubschrauber explodiert die geisel
stirbt auch der terrorist wird
erschossen ein weiterer
verletzt 0 05 die kommunikation ist ein
desaster regierungssprecher conrad
ahlers spricht im fernsehen den völligen
ihr glauben von einer glücklichen und
gut verlaufenen aktion 19 ein weiterer
terrorist mit von einem scharfschützen
erschossen
und 15 drei palästinenser leben noch sie
werden von der polizei festgenommen
die bilanz nach 21 katastrophalen stunde
15 tote neun israelische geiseln ein
deutscher polizist und fünf
palästinensische terroristen
ja keine absolut katastrophale bilanz
und das ging katastrophal weiter
springen nach vorn 29 oktober
1972 nur sieben wochen nach dem attentat
von münchen in beirut entführen zwei
palästinenser eine lufthansa maschine um
die attentäter von münchen freizupressen
deutschland lässt sich erneut erpressen
während israel jagd auf die terroristen
machen will
das ziel der operation zorn gottes ist
klar die zwei überlebenden terroristen
von münchen und deren drahtzieher zu
liquidieren der israelische geheimdienst
macht jagd auf mutmaßliche
verantwortliche in beirut paris und rom
am ende der 20 jahre andauernden
mörderjagd sind mindestens 14
terroristen und eine unbekannte anzahl
an unschuldigen zivilisten und
polizisten tot
rückblick drei der terroristen von
münchen überleben die wilde schießerei
am flughafen fürstenfeldbruck
sie werden festgenommen und inhaftiert
doch nur sieben wochen später am 29
oktober
1972 werden die drei durch eine
flugzeugentführung freigepresst in der
libanesischen hauptstadt beirut bekommen
zwei palästinensische luftpiraten die
lufthansa-maschine kiel in ihre gewalt
entführen sie nach zagreb und fordern
die freilassung der terroristen von
münchen die deutsche regierung geht
erstaunlich schnell auf die forderung
ein bringt die terroristen ebenfalls
erstaunlich schnell nach zagreb von dort
fliegen die flugzeugentführer geiseln
und die befreiten terroristen nach
tripolis libyen kaum dort angekommen
halten die täter von münchen eine
zynische pressekonferenz
ich war mir sicher dass ich eines tages
frei sein werde
sie waren sich sicher dass es innerhalb
von zwei monaten sein wird
ich weiß nicht sieben tage zwei monate
drei monate das ist mir egal ich war mir
sicher dass meine freunde mich in unser
land holen werden
ich habe beschlossen jeden einzelnen von
ihnen auf spüren zu lassen wir werden
sie jagen bis wir den letzten zur
strecke gebracht haben wurde die den
rachedurst eines landes widerspiegeln
sie sind beginn einer staatlich
sanktionierten mörderjagd namens zorn
gottes
nach außen ging es nicht um rache es
ging darum einem weiteren anschlag
zuvorzukommen
rom
1972 der palästinensische dichter und
verherrliche des schwarzen septembers
weil sowie tier wird hier am 16 oktober
mit zwölf schüssen aus einer pistole
getötet
beirut 1973 hier findet am 19 april die
größte zorn gottes operation statt 15
mossad-agenten drei von ihnen als frauen
verkleidet gehen mit schlauchbooten am
strand des hotels sense beach an land
und erstürmen zwei häuser bei rot
1979 hier spürt der mossad ali hassan
salameh ein führungsmitglied der
terrororganisation schwarzer september
auf
paris 1992 der planer des münchen
terrors aktiv bei so wurde am 8 juni vor
dem hotel meridian niedergeschossen
[Musik]
jemanden festzunehmen ist schwieriger
als ihn zu töten und wir sahen es als
maßnahme den nächsten anschlag zu
verhindern diese typen hätten einfach
auf der welle des erfolgs mehr lust auf
weitere anschläge bekommen können
deshalb stand für uns die verhinderung
weiterer anschläge im vordergrund und
sie einfach zu exekutieren wurde als
einfacher betrachtet als einen nach dem
anderen den gerichtsprozess zu machen
eine reihe von prozessen die
generationen gedauert hätten
nur drei terroristen die in verbindung
zum attentat in münchen standen entkamen
der rache israels die zwei durch die
entführung der lufthansa-maschine frei
gepressten und der ideengeber des
olympia anschlags abo drauf er stirbt
2010 eines natürlichen todes er soll die
kalaschnikow gewehre besorgt und das
papier der israelischen mannschaft
auskundschaftet haben die israelische
regierung hat die liquidation kampagne
der wald für erledigt erklärt
und genau diesen abu daud diesen
strippenzieher und ideengeber ein
ehemaliger lehrer aus ost-jerusalem der
sich dem geheimdienst von plo chef
jassir arafat angeschlossen hatte denart
unser chefreporter peter hell damals
jahre später getroffen wieder erzählt
uns von dieser begegnung das war 2006 in
kairo das war eine sehr skurrile
begegnung wir hatten vorher kontakt
versucht aufzunehmen zu abo der damals
in damaskus lebte in syrien das war das
land wo er noch leben durfte hatte er
überall einreiseverbot wurde gesucht und
stand natürlich noch auf interpol und
der hat sich bis dato auch nicht vor
einem gericht verpflichten oder oder
verantworten müssen und er kam dann ins
hotel das war alles schon sehr
geheimnisvolle hat uns kurz vorher
gesagt wann und wo wir ihn treffen
können und dann kam er an und wir
wussten natürlich noch oder abend
vermutet dass wir vielleicht sogar noch
auf der fahndungsliste oder für einen
hit team von dem israeli steht als er
war sehr vorsichtig dann kam er auch an
die rezeption und legte fünf pässe in
kairo und das ägypten war das einzige
land wo hin reisen konnte und da stand
auch fünf nabend auf das waren die namen
mit der an der auch den letzten 20
jahren davor um gereist ist und wir sind
dann mit ihm hoch gegangen haben das
interview geführt und das war schon sehr
ja
befremdlich natürlich man sitzt
gegenüber einem menschen der
verantwortlich ist für diese furchtbare
tat und er redet darüber als ob er
gerade irgendwie ein wunderbares gericht
zubereitet hatte er sagt er bereut
nichts die palästinenser haben das
hätten das recht dazu gehabt und er
sagte die haben uns ausgeladen aus den
von den olympischen spielen die
palästinensische sportler und dann haben
wir beschlossen wie wir mit unseren
mitteln daran doch teilnehmen und das
haben sie geben auch gezeigt und er hat
dann eben aus dem nähkästchen geplaudert
wie eben dann in den folgejahren
untergetaucht ist auch in der ddr wie er
mit top terroristen mit carlos zusammen
in prag war wie sie getrunken haben wie
sie also man kann sagen sex sozialismus
und terror also eine ganz skurrile
geschichte eigentlich das war schon sehr
interessant die frage ist halt was
stimmt davon und was ist so ein bisschen
propaganda da muss man immer aufpassen
sagt sex sozialismus und terror was
hatte die stasi damit zu tun die stasi
war sehr involviert bei abu daud man hat
ihnen ab 1978 einreisen lassen in die
ddr und erstmal sehr vorsichtig man
wusste wer er war
abu daud hatte kontakt wer war bei der
verdacht er hatte kontakt zu anderen
vertrag für führen und auch zum
internationalen terrorismus auch zu
deutschen raf terroristen auch zu diesem
top terroristen carlos und die ddr hatte
damals interesse daran informationen
abzuschöpfen und man wusste welches funk
mann hatte man versteckte ihn auch in
der ddr und hat dann gemerkt da gibt uns
gute information und wir lassen ihn
japan ihnen ein bisschen dafür soll er
bitte keine terroranschläge von ddr
boden aus starten und dann ist eben
etwas einschneidendes passiert 1981 in
einem hotel in warschau im victoria
hotel hat sich abu daud mal wieder
getroffen mit anderen terroristen hat
sich da in polen relativ sicher gefühlt
und ist dann von einer person
angeschossen worden mit fünf schüssen
einen schuss gegen ins gesicht einer in
den bauch er hat überlebt vermutlich
waren ist oder war es ein entwickeltes
israelischen kommandos und dann hat man
gesagt
wir holen ihn zurück und auf befehl von
stasi chef erich mielke hat man ein
sondermaschine eingesetzt und hat ihn
dann zurück in die ddr gebracht wo er
dann in einem krankenhaus in berlin und
ost berlin buch perfekt behandelt hat
und versorgt also eine sehr aktive rolle
der stasi dort der ddr wir haben auch
mit professor doktor daniela münkel
darüber gesprochen wir haben mal kurz
rein was sie gesagt hat der wert aber
dauert für die ddr bzw die stasi lag auf
mehreren ebenen zum einen war er ein
wichtiger informant über die strömung
innerhalb der palästinensischen
organisation
aber auch um kontakte zu anderen
terroristischen vereinigungen
herzustellen und er wusste eben auch was
sozusagen im internationalen terrorismus
gespielt wurde ja die hat es sich hier
gut gehen lassen sowie ein lebemann hat
man sich das vorzustellen die stasi wie
gesagt beobachteten und hält das alles
fest dass von frauengeschichten die rede
er hatte wohl mehrere geliebte in der
ddr von den teuren hotels von von gutem
essen von viel alkohol und das war für
die offenbar kein widerspruch was wurde
eigentlich aus den anderen beiden
attentätern den anderen beiden
terroristen ja auch diese nicht
verurteilt worden dabei handelt sich um
mohammed safadi und ramallah gaza diese
beiden terroristen haben es vor kurzem
ein interview ein fernsehinterview
gegeben und auch da war unisono zu
verhören zu verlauten sie bereuen ganz
sie sind die helden eigentlich im
arabischen raum bei weiten teilen der
arabischen bevölkerung und da können sie
sich auch gut frei
aufhalten einer soll sich in afrika bis
dato versteckt haben also sie versuchen
natürlich dann auch vielleicht auch
eventuell
möglichen die teams fordern von israel
ist zu entkommen der dienst also an
schläger aus dem italienischen dem
israelischen geheimdienst
vielen dank peter für den moment hier im
studium wir schauen gleich auf die die
dieses ganze leid ertragen mussten auf
die angehörigen der opfer von münchen
heute waren sie da in münchen zusammen
mit bundespräsident steinmeier und dem
israelischen präsidenten herzog haben
sie der opfer von vor 50 jahren in
münchen gedacht bis gleich
[Musik]
bis heute können die hinterbliebenen der
opfer des attentats nicht begreifen
wieso die warnungen damals nicht ernst
genommen worden waren wie so ihre männer
und väter nicht besser geschützt worden
waren wieso das versagen nicht
aufgearbeitet wurde und wieso
deutschland lange keine angemessene
entschädigung zahlen wollte wirtschaft
reporterin antonia jamin hat sie in
israel getroffen
[Musik]
an die spitze am grab ihres ermordeten
mannes erschossen von palästinensischen
terroristen mitten in deutschland ich
komme seit 50 jahren hierher und der
schmerz ist noch immer der gleiche
am 5 september
1972 werden elf israelische athleten
während der olympischen spiele in
münchen
kaltblütig ermordet
fünf von ihnen sind auf diesem friedhof
in tel aviv begraben
hier ist ein davidstern und tier liegt
oper andré und tieren seine freunde
meine enkelin ist fünf jahre alt sie
heißt nina sie kommt hierher und pflegt
die goldenen inschriften an den krebs
half grüße von oma dann hat sie ihr ohr
auf das grab gelegt und gesagt aber er
antwortet nicht
andere spitze antwortet seiner frau anni
seit 50 jahren nicht mehr um das
schweigen und die lehre zu ertragen
sucht anki trost bei elena romano
auch ihr mann wurde von den terroristen
in münchen ermordet als songwriter die
katastrophe traf uns als wir 26 jährige
junge frauen waren
anti hatte ein neugeborenes baby und ich
hatte drei töchter eine sechsjährige
eine vierjährige und eine war erst fünf
monate alt
josef romano elenas ehemann war israels
meister im gewicht heben als die
terroristen in den wohnkomplex der
israelischen delegation
einbrechen wehrt er sich greift sie an
mit einem obstmesser
die hätten ihn einfach erschießen können
aber was haben sie gemacht sie haben ihn
gefoltert schreckliche bilder das kann
man sich überhaupt nicht vorstellen
er hatte ein weißes t shirt an und der
ganze untere teil war in fetzen gerissen
in diesen stunden ist angeber ihren
eltern in den niederlanden verfolgt den
anschlag im fernsehen sie weiß bereits
dass ihr mann als geisel genommen wurde
wird es kritisch plötzlich sah ich um
halb sechs im fernsehen die das fenster
aufgerissen wurde und da sah ich
angeregt die behörden fragten ihn wie
die situation im zimmer sei also
antwortete er ihnen dass alle bis auf
einen in ordnung sein dann durfte er
nicht weiter reden und ich habe gesehen
wie sie ihn mit der kalaschnikows ins
zimmer geschoben haben dann haben sie
das fenster geschlossen und den vorhang
zugezogen das war das letzte mal dass
ich ihn gesehen
deutsche sicherheitskräfte starten eine
rettungsaktion
sie versagen
diese arroganz der deutschen die
demütigende haltung immer hin wollte
israel eine spezialeinheit schicken um
einen rettungsversuch zu unternehmen
deutschland hat nein gesagt auf keinen
fall wir wissen was wir tun was habt ihr
denn genau getan ihr habt noch nicht mal
einen gerettet nicht ein
[Musik]
um viertel nach drei am morgen sah mir
plötzlich jay kay den bbc moderator mit
der gelben jacke er sagte heute morgen
waren die elf israelis noch am leben
doch zwei seien im olympischen dorf
ermordet worden und neun weitere am
flughafen
die behörden in deutschland weigern sich
die verantwortung für die vielen fehler
zu übernehmen
die akten sind in verschiedenen archiven
vergraben den witwen wird der zugang
verweigert
manfred schreiber der präsident der
münchner polizei er sagte mir ihr habt
den terror nach deutschland gebracht sie
sprechen von terroristen aber das waren
freiheitskämpfer und
dann der nächste große shop mit einer
flugzeug entführung werden die drei
überlebenden terroristen freigepresst
vor ein deutsches gericht kommen sie nie
sie haben uns betrogen die dachten die
witwen gehen stehen nach hause und
ziehen ihre kinder groß ja wir haben
unsere kinder zu ruhm erzogen und wir
haben auch weiter gekämpft ich
versichere ihnen der fleck auf der
deutschen weste wird noch viele viele
jahre bleiben mona münchen
[Musik]
50 jahre danach ist es klar viel zu viel
ist schief gegangen vor und während des
attentats aber auch danach und
auch mit überlebenden des attentats hat
antonia jamin in israel sprechen können
die olympischen spiele in deutschland
1972 es ist der fünfte september als
palästinensische terroristen brutal die
wohnungen nummer eins und drei in der
münchner koloniestraße 31 überfallen
hier wohnen israelische olympioniken ab
jetzt sind sie geiseln unter ihnen gar
bari er ist israels meister im ringen
und die einzige geisel der die flucht
vor den terroristen gelegt
bild -chef reporterin antonia jamin
trifft guard in seinem kleinen
restaurant in tel aviv
ist sie hier das erste base ist von den
olympischen spielen
ja das ist der einzug ins stadion da
sind alle noch am leben die nach
ermordet
[Musik]
weitere spiele sollen es 1972 werden die
welt sollte sehen die olympiade unter
dem hakenkreuz
1936 sie ist geschichte
deutschland hat sich verändert
deutschland ist friedlich offen sicher
für alle
ich erinnere mich noch an die wachleute
dort die liebe nicht wie polizisten und
nicht bewaffnet die liefen herum wie
kellner auf der straße
ungehindert dringend die terroristen in
das wohngebäude der israelischen
delegation ein erster tatort ist die
wohnung nummer eins
in der früh um halb fünf höre ich eine
explosion
ich habe das nicht ernst genommen dachte
vielleicht hat jemand eine medaille
geworden und feiert
so habe ich weiter geschlafen die sechs
israelischen sportler in wohnung nummer
eins sind nun geiseln die terroristen
stürmen weiter ihr nächstes ziel wohnung
nummer drei hier schlafen kabarett und
fünf seiner kameraden
nach 20 minuten hörte ich stimmen hinter
unserem zimmer also bin ich raus und da
stehe ich tatsächlich vor dem terror ist
das wahr ist damit der weißen mütze dann
sah mich und richtete sofort die
kalaschnikow nicht
den terroristen wohnungen 3 wird schnell
klar sie brauchen dringend ihre
kriminellen komplizen sie zwingen die
jüdischen sportler aus dem raum der
erste von ihnen im korridor ist kabarett
mich hat es verrückt gemacht dass er die
kalaschnikow richtig in mich rein geburt
hat damit ich verstehe was er will damit
ich auf die andere seite gehen deshalb
habe ich mit einem schlag die
kalaschnikow von meinem bauch
weggeschlagen
bis heute ist die flucht in graz
gedächtnis präsent freundin die ihn im
restaurant besuchen erzählte davon dass
ist der zickzack zwischen dem freiland
der terrorist ist hier ja und ich rennen
im zickzack nur in der unterhose siehst
du das
hat er oft sich geschossen als du
weggerannt bist ja aber er hat mich
nicht getroffen in einer der wohnungen
schläft auch schauer adani er hat den
holocaust überlebt bei den olympischen
spielen
1972 entkommt er nur knapp dem tod gegen
halb sechs uhr morgens weckte man mich
und dann sagte mir man hat nie einen
sportler in der delegation ermordet ohne
viel nachzudenken steckte ich meine füße
in die sportschuhe ich bin immer noch im
pyjama aber geht zur haustür und öffne
sie ihn rechts von mir am eingang zur
wohnung nummer eins steht jemand er
trägt eine sturmhaube und schaut
geradeaus vor ihm stehen vier wachleute
des olympischen dorfes alle unbewaffnet
und in pastellfarben der kleidung unter
ihnen eine frau sie bittet den
maskierten im roten kreuz zu erlauben
einzutreten und jemanden zu helfen ich
sagte ihm er solle menschlich sein er
antwortet die jugend sind auch nicht
menschlich neuen aussehen aus angst auch
als geisel genommen zu werden fliehen
scholz mitbewohner schauwand noch den
delegationsleiter in wohnung nummer 5
zusammen entkommen sie über den balkon
mein charakter wurde halt durch den
holocaust geprägt
ich habe so viel durchgemacht und ich
denke dass ich ein stück weit immun
geworden bin ich die leute sehen
am frühen morgen sind elf von charles
sportkameraden tot
aber die olympischen spiele in
deutschland sollen weitergehen
die sportler kehre nach hause zurück elf
von ihnen in särgen verstaut eine kaum
zu ertragenden niederlage den nord
arabische länder haben jahrelang
versucht uns von allen möglichen sport
foren auszuschließen und hier nachdem
sie unser blut vergossen befriedigen wir
unsere feinde und verlassen das
olympische forum und verschwinden wenn
er
lebt und atmet geschichte seine ganz
private aber auch die seines volkes und
heute also das gedenken 50 jahren nach
denen die palästinensischen terroristen
auf dem flughafen fürstenfeldbruck neun
israelische geiseln und einen deutschen
polizisten erschossen waren angehörige
der opfer heute dort der israelische
präsident war da und bundespräsident
steinmeier bat um vergebung
elf israelische sportler werden bei den
olympischen spielen 1972 in münchen
durch terroristen ermordet der deutsche
staat versagt im vorfeld beim schutz der
sportler bei der befreiung der geiseln
und in den folgenden 50 jahren bei der
aufklärung des versagens und der
kommunikation
ein vorgang den bundespräsident
steinmeier
gedenkfeier mit deutlichen worten
beschreibt ich bitte sie als
staatsoberhaupt dieses landes und dem
namen der bundesrepublik deutschland
um vergebung und vergebung für den
mangelnden schutz der israelischen
athleten
damals bei den olympischen spielen in
münchen
und für die mangelnde aufklärung danach
dafür
das geschehen konnte
das geschehen ist gekommen sind auch
hinterblieben jetzt den erst vor wenigen
tagen eine einigung über
entschädigungszahlen
mit ihnen zusammen liegen steinmeier und
israels staatspräsident
isaac herzog grenze auf dem flughafen
fürstenfeldbruck
es ist meine pflicht und mein bedürfnis
unsere deutsche verantwortung zu
bekennen hier und heute und für die
zukunft
die hinterbliebenen zeigen sich berührt
und dankbar über die rede von steinmeier
sowie die zahlung von fast 30 mio
[Musik]
das gesagt gesagt
das könnte man auch sagen vor 50 jahren
zudem sollen bislang verschlossene akten
zu den ereignissen zugänglich gemacht
werden
wirtschaft reporterin antonia jamin über
die letzten tage dabei in der
israelischen delegation hat also ganz
nah alles miterlebt sie ist gerade mit
dieser delegation auf dem weg nach
berlin und deshalb habe ich sie vor dem
abflug in münchen gefragt was die
bewegendsten momente heute waren
ja also es gab es natürlich heute ganz
viele bewegende momente aber ich würde
sagen dass der große moment also der
highlight von diesem tag ist natürlich
die rede von bundespräsident steinmeier
er hat hier vor paar stunden gestanden
und hat um vergebung gebeten
er hat gesagt es dürfte nicht gestehen
ich bitte um vergebung dass es geschehen
ist dass es geschehen durfte sagt es ist
meine pflicht heute hier in deutschland
die verantwortung zu kennen heute jetzt
aber auch für die zukunft ist natürlich
sehr starke worte dass der präsident
benutzt hat und die sind auch angekommen
bei diesen familien bei den familien von
11 ermordeten israelis das sind leute
die 50 jahre lang für diese worte genau
gewartet haben und heute haben sie diese
worte bekommen heute haben sie dass
diese anerkennung bekommen und das war
hier sehr sehr bewegend
die frage stand ja auch lange im raum ob
die angehörigen überhaupt kommen würden
und auch die antonia getroffen hat und
wie sie diesen tag dann erlebt haben
also die familien die angehörigen
wussten ja bis vor paar tage überhaupt
nicht dass sie hierher kommen werden die
haben ja gesagt die werden nicht nach
fürstenfeldbruck münchen heute kommen
heute waren sie aber trotzdem da haben
diese gedenkzeremonie mitgehört und
haben sich auch vorher schon mit dem
bundespräsident mit steinmeier getroffen
die israelische delegation hier ist sehr
groß über 200 menschen aus israel sind
heute nach münchen angereist und wir
haben natürlich auch heute die witwen
hier gesehen ich habe mit ihrer romane
gesprochen sofort nachdem sie mit dem
bundespräsident steinmeier gesprochen
hat sie ist zitternd rausgekommen aber
wir haben gesehen dass sich sehr
berührend war sie hat uns gesagt zitat
ich liebe präsident steinmeier der hat
uns geholfen der hat alles getan damit
wir heute hier sind auch hinter den
kulissen er war sehr leises sehr still
hat jetzt nicht viel krach gemacht und
und große reden gehalten vor diesem tag
und hat einfach alles gemacht damit sie
heute hier sind und dann heute wie
gesagt diese wunderbare sehr sehr starke
rede gerne romane und an die spitze
balde witwen sagen mir wir fühlen uns
dass wir gewonnen haben endlich nach 50
jahren hat deutschland verantwortung
genommen und ich denke dass von heute an
auch die familien aber auch israel
endlich ein bisschen frieden über dieses
thema bekommen kann
ein wichtiger tag also antonia jamin ich
habe es zu beginn der sendung gesagt
meine damen und herren am vorabend des
attentats war deutschland wie im rausch
die erst 16 jährige schülerin ulrike
meyfarth hatte mit einem weltrekord
hochsprung völlig überraschend gold
geholt 50 jahre später sagte sie
kürzlich in einem interview dass sie
damals bald bemerkt habe dass über ihre
goldmedaille noch lange geredet werden
würde das aber kaum einer wissen würde
wie viele geiseln
bei dem attentat umgekommen sind es
waren 11 und sie werden nicht vergessen
[Musik]